Film Courage: Can we talk about that little
spark of an idea you had I believe it was in
your hometown in Alabama before you
came to Los Angeles? What was that
like? Andy Guerdat, Television Writer,
Producer, Instructor, and Podcaster:
It's the feeling that every writer should have
when they think of an idea. In my case I think
back on it now and I don't know why it came to
me, why I felt like it was, why it got me jazzed
but for some reason I had an image in my head
when I was very young and I was loving movies
but I wasn't quite sure how to if I had a place in
the movie and television industry but I had an it
just occurred to me wouldn't it be cool if there
was this married couple (upscale, married couple)
in a beautiful home, they're both attractive,
well-dressed. The husband is dressed for work,
goes out the front door, kisses his wife goodbye,
the door closes behind him and we hear the voice
over of a police detective saying When was the
last time you saw your husband, McCoughlin? That
was it, that's all. I was like that seems really
cool. I would want to watch that movie. Why would
a guy with a perfect life seemingly walk out the
front door and never come back? From that I built
a detective story which is called Fourth Story
eventually and structured it out. I didn't know
what I was doing but I had seen a lot of movies
and I sort of cobbled together what seemed like
a cool detective story. I eventually wrote it,
I came out here to Los Angeles and went to a
film school and started comparing it with
other people's work (professionals work)
and seeing what I'd done wrong and how I could
improve it. I rewrote it many times. The movie
eventually was bought and sold and optioned and
I rewrote it many times for different directors
and different actors and eventually it got made
years later. It all started with that spark and
that's true of every great film. Every great, film
somebody's has a little glimmer, just a spark.
sometimes they'll share with us the the writer
for example Brokeback Mountain the she's not a
screenwriter she's a fiction writer Annie Proulx
was in a bar and somewhere on the west and she's
sitting there and she's watching there's a pool
table and the young cowboy types are playing pool
and she looks over and there the sitting at the
bar as a crusty looking older cowboy watching the
younger cowboys play pool and it just flickered
in her head I wonder if he's gay and suddenly
given his age and where she was in the time and
place she thought that means he would have come
of age probably in the 50s, 1950s what would his
life have been like if he'd been gay, if he is gay
and from that she structured a short story called
Brokeback Mountain which then was optioned and
became the film that we all even people who've
never seen the film know the term Brokeback
Mountain that's how ubiquitous it became and that
was her moment and I call it an her moment you
are it's just a term I came up with it just means
the beginning the the the start of something the
that passionate flicker of excitement that that
that the original writer has and then which is
if you're lucky you get it transferred all the
way through the many drafts and onto the screen
obviously in the case of something like Brokeback
Mountain it worked but every movie has that thing
and only the original writer can track it down
and actually identify it unless they choose to
share it with us we don't usually know what that
moment was it very often isn't necessarily the
most famous scene in a movie but it's it has to
you need it to be there you the writer have to
have that in order to get yourself through this
experience of writing a structuring and writing
a screen p is going to take at the minimum weeks
and usually months if not years so you have to
keep coming back to that and saying what was it
I was excited about oh yeah that's what it is and
you keep breathing life on that little ember
that that if you've done it right still alive
and it flickers to life and it keeps you going
are we sharing that idea with others before and
I never share it nor should anyone else that's
yours to keep if you try to share it in the and
that's our instinct when we're starting out I got
this idea for a movie and if let's say I pitched
what I just told you was my my spark for a fourth
story and I shared that with somebody especially
somebody who wasn't a writer and of course when
you're starting out you're usually surrounded by
people who are not writers not creative and they
said I don't get it what would that it doesn't
seem that interesting oh gosh I guess I shouldn't
write it so never share it it's only yours no one
else needs to know it occasionally after a
movie is successful sometimes a screenwriter
in an interview or something will share it Alan
Ball shared his spark moment in the series in
The Go Draft [Andy’s Youtube channel] I call
it the er moment but he shared it for American
Beauty which was him one day sitting I think
it was in New York and watching a plastic bag
bob around in the wind and seeing how beautiful
it was and it's it was prosaic and other people
would have just thought it was litter but to him
he saw the beauty behind it and from that moment
he structured the movie American Beauty and that
scene is still there right to the it went through
many many many Dr before it got made but that
scene is still there the scene that I described
about for story I rewrote that script many times
it was right there at the very end it was still
there the whole time because it was the thing that
got me excited therefore it was probably going to
be the thing that got the producers excited
the director excited the actors excited and
ultimately the audience excited if you execute it
well enough and do you find in this era of I guess
you for lack of a better word oversharing online
in person wherever that it's hard to hold on to
that because we're we're kind of conditioned now
to show everything online or even with strangers
wherever that it's hard to kind of keep that ember
private anymore it's not hard for me but I'm not
from that era of social media and constant sharing
so I would imagine yes it probably is harder than
than one would think I one piece of advice is
to never share anything about your work with
anybody until unless it's a close personal friend
and preferably a close personal friend who is a
writer or an artist but it's best not to share
anything with anybody unless it's in some sort of
professional condition so that's if somebody says
give me a log line for your for the movie you're
working on don't just blurt something out think
about what that is think about what what that one
sentence or that elevator pitch as they call it
I used to call it a party pitch when somebody say
hey what are you doing and especially if you're
in LA and you're might going to meet actors and
agents and producers who knows where you're going
to meet them and you might get 20 30 seconds of
their attention hey what are you working on you
should have that party pitch down tight so that
you in in 20 or 30 seconds before you lose their
attention you're presenting your idea in the in
its best possible light in a professional light if
you just go around blurting out stuff you're doing
more harm than good most of the time the act of
presenting your material to a public even if it's
just one person at a party presenting it should be
taken seriously and same is true if you're writing
up a little treatment or a two-pager description
of your idea let's say an agent or a manager
somebody producer has asked you for it take your
time make sure it's right it's better to have it
right than have it fast and I never ever ever ever
send out a draft of anything I don't want to share
that until I know it's my best work the the the
the test I used to use and still do and advise
other people to do when you've gotten your draft
to a place where you think it's showable sharable
stop for a moment and picture what if I send this
out to whoever my contact list is and it comes
back a negative respond and people say I don't get
it I don't like it how would you feel would you
feel obviously you're going be disappointed but
would you feel disappointed and kicking yourself
I knew I should have not done another pass oh God
I why didn't I take a little more time with that
or would you say yeah I'm disappointed but that's
my best work and and maybe the timing was wrong or
whatever the planets didn't align this time I'm
hurt but I'm okay I'll live with that if that's
the second response is what you'd feel then it's
time for it to go out but if the first response is
what you'd feel don't send it out look at it again
you only get one first impression so you don't
want to you don't want to misuse it and and first
impression too with the party pitch even you're at
a barbecue yeah you can't go back and say oh
wait a minute what I really meant was you've
lost them already you get one shot so and if you
don't have it yet then just say oh I'm working on
a movie script maybe I'll can I call you later
and tell you about it but there's other ways to
do it but don't present it until it's ready to
be presented or better yet but go don't go to
a party unless you already have that in your head
if anybody asks me this is what I'm going to say
and think about it so it's as tight and as hooky
as possible so that it makes them want to say oh
that sounds kind of interesting when you're done
with that give me a wringle, give me a jingle I'd
like to talk about it more that's what you really
are going for in those moments and those moments
happen more often than you might think which is
one of the reasons why most people have to move
to Los Angeles to break in because it's hard to
do that if you're living in Birmingham, Alabama.